hello YouTube Chancellor's in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
second episode of dirty check strikes
against Sicilian in this lecture I'm
going to show you so the amazing and
wonderful tricks against Sicilian
Najdorf variation which arises after the
Mordor
efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captors d4
Knight captures before Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and in the last lecture we
have look at the dragon Venetian which
arises after the Moon g6 but this time
around the Najdorf variation is
characterized by this move that is a six
so the idea is very simple black is
stopping any Knight intrusion on the b v
square and in the future black and
expand with the b5 MO the foie streak
which I want to show you occurs in the
source and radiation which is
popularized by none other than mr.
Fischer himself that is to play Bishop
to c4 so you can see that Bishop is
posted on a wonderful diagonal and the
general theory of Najdorf goes with the
move e six so idea is now to play the
move b5 so white has to play the move
Bishop to b3 and now black has two most
popular setups the first move that is
Knight B to d7 has been popularized by
mr. Kasparov and the idea is to play the
move Knight to c5 and nab the bishop
there against this I'm recommending that
Y should play the move Bishop to g5
painting the night and it is a
characteristic of an astral player that
whenever this move appears on the ball
most of them are try to unpin this
Knight with the new Bishop to e7 and
this is where our trick straightaway
comes into the picture I want to
illustrate the key points of our tricks
now first of all you can easily see that
the last move Bishop to e7 has weakened
the g7 squared
severely and not only that right
now the e6 square is not well protected
by the bishop so this will allow us to
create this amazing piece sacrifice that
is Bishop captures c6 BAM if black
doesn't recapture then black will be a
point on for nothing
so obviously black has to recapture with
the app born and after Knight captures
c6 most of the NoScript player has
strived the move Queen to e-file idea is
to limit the activity of c3 Knight and
the same time keep an eye of the loose
bishop well here white will continue
with the Moon Knight captures g7 Czech
and after King to f7 you can easily see
that white has gained three points for a
piece and black king is stripped out in
the middle so this is a more than enough
compensation for an attacking player
here obviously white's two pieces are
hanging so white has to play the move
Knight to f4 attacking the d6 and this
is another big advantage of this line
you can easily see black cannot defend
the d6 square for example if black tried
to defend the d6 Square with the move
Queen to c7 then that comes Knight
captures e7 and not only white will
regain a piece but white is straight
away in the Willing position now to
illustrate how much dangerous this
position is once again I like to show
you one of my quick win in this line in
this game where my opponent was more
than 1,800 plus rated player he
responded with the move Knight to C Phi
so his idea is to free up the bishop and
do some counter attack on the White King
side well here I first of all capture
this Knight so there is a tack on the
rook as well and if black recapture with
the bishop then Queen to h5 is a very
lethal move so in the game my opponent
responded with the move King captures f6
well afterwards I'll continue with the
move Queen to default check and my
opponent play with this King
that is king 2e6 here i can easily
capture the rook in the corner but I
found a stronger continuation that is
Knight captures a seven so my opponent
save his rook and counter-attack on my
night with the move look to edge and now
comes a second stronger move that is
before attacking to pieces so the
another piece goes back that is Queen to
d8 now I save my night with the move
Knight to d5
so that means Black has the only MU left
that is he has to move his knight
otherwise black will be a piece down for
nothing so in the game my opponent
decided to play the move Knight to d7
but the end is we're in the air before I
show you my next move I want you to
pause the video and find out there is a
one move that almost finished black off
okay I hope you find this move that is
Queen to g7 so idea is very simple white
wants to play the Moon Knight to f4 and
that will be the checkmate
after a few minute thinking luckily my
opponent spotted this and he played the
move looked to a phage but when you lose
it you just lose after White's next move
that is Knight to e2 there is no escape
for the mating attack my opponent
resigned at this one
now the same sort of pattern you can
find in another variation that is at
this point if black plays the move b5
then I recommend that white should
continue with the move Bishop to g5
obviously black is going to play the
move Bishop to e7 and still the e6 pawn
is well protected by the bishop so it's
another time for the sacrifice but White
has the good move that is Queen to f3 so
idea is to play the move e5 and
attacking two pieces so obviously many
your player will stop this while the
move Bishop to b7 yes indeed it's
stopping the ephah advance but it
created the theme which we want that is
now g7e six become severely week and our
familiar pattern will come into the
picture that is yup Bishop captures c6
BAM f captures e6 and Knight captures a
six more or less the same story black
will play the move Queen to e5 Knight
captures g7 check King to f7 and this
time around white even do not need to
play the move Knight to f5 so once again
I'd like to show you one of my own game
where I responded with the move Bishop
captures six and after black recapture I
simply play the move Knight to f5 so
once again we are threatening the b6
square my opponent responded here with
the move rook to the edge and now
another good moon that is castle on the
Queen side you can see black is having a
great difficulty not only defending the
d6 square but his King is wide open here
my opponent after long thinking come out
with the move Bishop captures c3 so his
idea is to create a counter-attack on my
Queen side but what he missed is after
Knight captures d6 check which is a
double check of course the King goes to
the g8 square I give another check that
is Queen to f7 and after King to ochite
he missed a simple but very effective
move that is Knight captures peace am in
the game is finished right there he's
tried some cheapos that is Bishop
captures B to check but I just sidestep
everything with the MU King to be one he
captured my rook I recapture and now in
the view of Queen is hanging he played
the move Queen to b6 but he complete the
meeting that is Quint f8
checkmate so those are some of the
wonderful tricks in the source and
variation now the final trick I want to
show you it's it occurs in the main line
with the move Bishop to g5 after the
move Bishop to g5 the main line goes as
follows black plays the movie six and
white responded here with the move and
for black respond with the move Bishop
to e7 and now Queen to f3 so idea is to
castle quickly on the Queen side and go
for the King side attack here the theory
goes with the bull Knight to d7 and
after castle on the Queen side black
plays the move Queen to c7 why continue
his expansion on the Kings side with the
moon g4 and likewise black continued his
attack on the Queen side the move b5 and
the trap set it right over here here
white has this amazing move that is
Bishop captures up six there are three
mates black and recapture but two of
them are very bad if black capture with
the gee-pole then it is very obvious
that black King will be remain in the
center and not only that what has this
positional threat of the move f5 so that
is not good if black capture with the
knight which is considered as to be the
main line but after this move White has
the tremendous initiative that is to
play the G file and when the night drop
backs to the d7 why it has another
advance that is F file so you can
already see what is gaining a quite a
bit initiative there so considering all
this after Bishop captures f6 many
natural player plays the move Bishop
captures f6 and thinking what can be
wrong with this move well here our trick
comes into the picture now you can
already see Bishop captures c6 has
weakened the d6 square significantly
that means what can exploit this
magnificently with this amazing
sacrifice the shot captures beef i BAM
now if black doesn't recapture then
obviously black is going to be a pawn
down for nothing so we should obviously
see what happens
after black capture the piece so a
captures b5 and obviously night D
captures beef eye with an attack on the
Queen I reach this position only in one
game where my opponent played here the
move Queen to BH obviously white is
gaining three points for a piece and
with attack to boot my opponent
responded over here with the move King
to FH but this is actually a big mistake
before we go on I want you to pause the
video and find a continuation where
white is completely winning okay I hope
you find this moon that is night cap to
see it
Queen cap to see it now the move ePHI
attacking the bishop and when the bishop
drop back somewhere for example let's
say in the game my opponent plays the
move Bishop to e7 yeah rook captures d7
so not only regaining the piece but
white is a clear free pawn a head in the
game and not to mention attack to boot
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on my video and I'll meet you in my next
episode bye